so the last video we we studied a
circumstance where i had a 70 free throw
probability i have a 70 chance of making
any free throw which is actually higher
than my my actual free throw probability
which might be a surprise to you but we
said in that circumstance if it's a 70
chance of making it well that means that
you have a 1 minus 70 or 30 chance of
missing and we said if you took six
attempts the probability of you getting
exactly making two of the baskets
exactly two scores and i call them
scores instead of making it just because
i wanted making and miss having
different letters in that video we said
well there's six choose two different
ways of making two exactly two out of
the six free throws and then the
probability of any one of those ways is
going to be making it twice which is 0.7
squared time and missing it four times
so 0.3 to the fourth power so this was
just one particular situation but we
could generalize based on the logic that
we had in that video in fact let's do
that so if i were to generalize it if i
were to say the probability
the probability it's the exact same
logic of exactly
exactly
let's say k
let me do this in a color an interesting
color so let me do it in this
orange brown color k
k
shots or exactly k scores i'll call
making a free throw a score we'll just
assume you've got a point for it so
exactly two k scores
k scores
in
in n attempts let's just say in n
attempts
in n and let me go back to that green
color and
attempts
and attempts
is going to be equal to
well how many ways can you pick k things
out of n or n choose k
and
choose k
choose
k
and then actually let's just generalize
it even more let's just say that you
have your free throw probability is p so
let's say
let's say p
is so for this situation right over here
since we generalize it fully let's say
that p
is the probability of making a free
throw actually since i already have a p
here let me just say
f
is equal to the probability
of
making
making a free throw or you could say
your probability of scoring if you call
a score making making a free throw so if
f is your probability of making a free
throw so if you want n scores then this
is going to be
this is going to be well it's going to
be f
to the n power and then you're going to
have and then you're going to miss the
remainder sorry f to the k power
because you're making exactly k scores
so f
to the
k power
and then the remainder so the n minus k
attempts you're going to miss it so it's
going to be that probability of missing
and the probability of missing is going
to be 1 minus f
so it's going to be times
times 1
minus f
to the
n minus k power
to the n
minus k power
and just if you like or i encourage you
pause the video and just make sure you
understand the parallels between this
this example where i had a set where you
know i guess our f was 70 our f was
seventy percent one minus f or our f was
point seven and one minus f would be
point three and we were seeing how do we
get two scores in six attempts and here
we're saying k scores in n attempts and
this is just a general way to think
about it and the whole reason why i'm
setting this up this way
is it's interesting to now think about
the probability distribution for a
random variable that's defined by the
number of scores in your n attempts or
the number of scores in your six
attempts and actually since i've been
pushing the limit in or you know i've
been doing longer videos that i tend to
i will do that in the next video